so welcome all of you and
congratulations on passing the first
test of the evening which of course is
the elevate
and this is the fifth instantiation of
the atom and an Amy Perry lecture and we
are delighted to be able to welcome back
to Yale
Glen most is a W but I don't know what
the W is for Glenn Warren most and it is
to distinguish you from but you are so
it is has become customary for me to do
the ice-breaking and David to do the
substantive introduction so that's what
we're going to do I will tell you when I
first met Glenn most which was in the
spring I think of 1980 when he walked
into art Hansen's office at Princeton
where I was a senior and shot him with a
water pistol he had just been hired as
an assistant professor is going to be
starting in that fall I think either by
luck or by design art had a windbreaker
on so no permanent damage was done since
then
Glenn has taught at in Siena in
Innsbruck getting the order wrong here
in Heidelberg and he is currently
professor of Greek at the School in
Ramallah in Pisa and also on the
committee for social thought in Chicago
where he also has appointments in
complet and classics so this is
befitting his career where he has gone
from classics undergraduate degree to at
some Community College in Cambridge to a
Yale PhD and complet and then to PhD is
a second PhD in classics and David is
going to tell you all about his work
which ranges from X to feel all oogy
to crazy theory and back again
well it's a particular privilege for me
to introduce professor gland most he's
about the leading scholars in our time
of ancient Greek literature and language
and his interests and published work
encompassed the history of classical
scholarship philosophy ancient and
modern poetry history of art and many
others which I'm just not going to get
around to
he's a comparative in the deepest sense
of that term he's fluent in speaking and
writing in German French and Italian as
well as English and he writes on
literature in those languages as well
from antiquity to to the present he's a
scholar and critic extraordinaire and
he's a very appropriate person for us to
have for the parry lecture series this
is also a happy occasion
for me to express my gratitude for a
friendship personal and intellectual
that began when Glen and I were graduate
students here together in comparative
literature and that continued when we
young professors at Princeton when we
were young professors at Princeton and
then over many years to come
professor most received his PhD in this
department
he had his orals and moment of Terror in
this room as I did and he had a
dissertation on poetic truth in the
Romantic period and you can imagine with
whom that was he worked and at the same
time he received a PhD at the University
of Tuebingen and classical philology
with dissertation on Pindar so two
dissertations in the same year and I
will repeat what Chris just said he is
presently professor Greek follow G at
the schooner valley de Pisa he is the
busy professional social thought the
University of Chicago and he is the
external scientific member of the Max
Planck Institute for the history of
science in Berlin so I will now take up
all of the lecture time allotted to
Professor
very citing his publications well that's
not gonna happen
I would need 10 tongues and 10 mouths
and a heart of bronze to do so but I
will try to give you something of an
idea of the range and accomplishment of
his the range and accomplishment an
early book on Pindar showed in startling
detail how at least some of the ODEs
could disclose a self-conscious verbal
architecture in more recent years he has
been the editor and translator of the
now 2 vol Loeb classical library Hesiod
and with Andre locks of the Bellator
edition of the metaphysics of Deif
Rastus and again with locks of the nine
volumes count'em Loeb series on early
Greek philosophy the philosophers who
used to be known as pre-socratics he has
written two monographs on art history
one on Raphael celebrated fresco at the
School of Athens whose iconographically
most argues derives in part from a
passage and Plato's Pythagoras one that
starts with Caravaggio's painting of
doubting Thomas in which most examines
the whole tradition and commentary and
artistic representation behind this
skeptic who wants to touch rather than
see in an age when the real presence of
Christ in the sacrament was a burning
issue most as one of the editors of the
scholarly edition of Nietzsche's works
he is part of a team of editors and
translators into German of the works of
Arnaud alleluia know and in the same
vein of reconstructing the history of
classical scholarship he is translated
to English with Anthony Grafton and
James Etzel Friedrich Wolf's prologue
homage to Homer and on his own
Sebastiano Tempah narrows to the genesis
of lachman's method he is the editor for
Greek entries of the 12 volume der neue
poly
Paulo de Silva in fact it's 13 but who's
counting especially if you're
triskaidekaphobia
he is co-edited 9 collections of essays
by different hands ranging on subjects
from homer the Devaney papyrus Greek
Theater anger in the ancient world
and Virgil one of the earliest of these
the poetics of murder is a collection of
critical essays on detective fiction
which contains most trenchant essay on
the difference between the British and
American traditions it's a brilliant
essay he told me at the time that the
alternate title was going to be sleuth
and Method but it didn't happen recently
he is co-editor volume together with
Anthony Grafton artful illogical method
in a variety of canonical written
traditions entitled canonical text and
scholarly practices a global comparative
approach that's cambridge 2016 professor
most has written some 200 articles so
even ten tongues are not going to do it
but it is worth pointing out some
classic ones his essay on the structure
and function of disease apology that is
a key analysis of the structure of the
odyssey and i would add to that also an
early essay published in italian that
does something similar for the Odysseys
underworld his witty and brilliant
reflecting Sappho that reminds us that
our view of Sappho whether gay or
straight has to consider grammar and the
Eamonn Dacians of editors his piece on
Heidegger's Greeks which tells us that
these Greeks are really Germans in not
much disguise and in Roman togas to boot
what characterizes most scholarship and
I here come to my horse conclusion
beyond its keen eye for verbal detail
beyond its full logical mastery and
massive erudition is this ability to
bring text and images into conversation
with human issues sometimes the largest
human
and as a reflection of most the person
who takes an immense delight and
scholarship that is where the energy
behind this extraordinary achievement
comes from and who takes scholarship
absolutely seriously without taking
himself so seriously the mischievous wit
that keeps surfacing in his prose and in
his person is also a form of reflection
and distancing that is deeply humane and
humanistic his title today is about
those who can laugh even at themselves
weeping Heraclitus and laughing
Democritus please join me in welcoming
professor nose
[Applause]
this is a emotional moment for me not
only to be surrounded by young people
and to see very dear friends who have
said very touching things about me but
also to be in the room where as David
said 42 years ago I had my orals
examination in comparative literature
there are five professors in around the
table and there was me and I was
terrified and I can't be in this room
now without feeling some of that terror
I think out of the doors are going to
come like in Macbeth the ghosts by
examiner's to talk with me and asked me
did I really read that passage in Proust
the talk that I'm going to be giving you
today is derived in a certain sense from
two parents one is my continuing
interest in the reception of antiquity
in the Renaissance and one is the work
that I've been doing for the past two
many years on the people who used we
call the pre-socratics today I'm going
to be looking much more at the Greek
side of it and much less at the
Renaissance Renaissance side of it but
I'll begin with that my subject is a
commonplace of European painting and
engraving in the Renaissance especially
Dutch art especially in the 17th century
it also appears in literature and in
philosophy for example in long tense
essays for example in Robert Burton's
anatomy of melancholy which is authored
by Democritus jr. what the paintings and
etchings always show are two male
figures almost always the upper half of
their body never just the face and never
the full body or almost
ever one of them is laughing often in a
snide or contemptuous manner
the other one is sad or is even weeping
these are Democritus and Heraclitus very
often they're shown with a globe which
represents human affairs these are two
opposite ways in which people can react
to human life either they can feel pity
or grief at human folly that the
disasters which people caused themselves
or they can feel amusement or scorn in a
certain sense they're observing from
outside the world there's any theatrical
theatre Mundi aspect of this that I will
come back to later either the
philosopher like her colitis can feel
sorrow at the stupidity of human beings
who cannot be rescued from their own
folly or he feels amused by it like
Democritus ultimately does their
misfortune matter to him or does it not
does he count himself as one of them or
is someone who is separate from and
different from them what all of these
pictures show is the failure of
philosophy to establish human happiness
how does the philosopher react to the
failure philosophy the earliest that of
these paintings that has been identified
is by Bramante in 1477 and then after a
break of about a century or so it starts
up again in the second half of the 16th
century and gradually dies out in the
first half of the 18th century I'm going
to give you a quick parade through some
of them just so you can see the kinds of
variations and the kinds of basic
structure that are found in this
iconography there have been at least 80
that have been counted in the standard
Dutch article on the subject I found
quite easy
another five or six and I'm sure there's
well over a hundred out there so this is
just to introduce you to it sometimes
democritus seems to be laughing at her
ik lightest sometimes Democritus is
younger than her ik lightest often
Democritus is pointing in ridicule while
Heraclitus rings his hands in anguish
why are these paintings so popular for
one thing they show classical exemplar
great people of antiquity who
established norms that can still be
applied today there's an aspect of
humanism here and the kind of low-level
humanistic scholarship addressed to
relatively educated spectators not
overly educated but well enough in order
to be able to identify them or to point
to them in front of their guests and to
speak about them the paintings are
interesting for their artists and for
their spectators I suppose also because
of their expression of emotions
heightened by contrast there are always
just two there's never only one and
there's never more than two and so the
two antithetical emotions exaggerated
and polarize one another in so doing
they stimulate emotions in the viewer so
there's a rhetorical aspect it's a good
psychic Gajic aspect the portraits are
portraits of individuals who are at the
same time representations of types each
one is highly individual and yet at the
same time they have a generality about
them especially in their contrast one
thinks here of Theophrastus is correct
characters and of the whole physiognomic
tradition the content is didactic semi
philosophical in a way there's typical
of Renaissance Dutch painting but the
fact that it's philosophic or didactic
doesn't it all exclude a dimension to
these images which is satirical and
comic after all these philosophers are
often themselves rather ridiculous
figures they're dirty ugly bedraggled
befuddled they don't seem to be
hi element to hide paradigms for us to
imitate if anything they're cynical
philosophers very often Democritus seems
to win and her Heraclitus seems to lose
in most of the paintings
it is Democritus who is looking at us
and is establishing a scornful
conspiracy together with us against her
equators her GLaDOS is sullen and
withdrawn exaggeratedly melancholy
Democritus seems to be making fun of him
and not only of the world
well where does this topples of the
post-classical pictorial arts come from
how did it come about not in any case I
suggest directly from one or more
ancient pictorial artworks no such
victor portrayals of weeping
Heraclitus and laughing Democritus have
survived from antiquity if there ever
were any such and I shall come back to
this question later instead what we have
here is a modern artistic visualization
of an ancient literary commonplace which
is found in a number of ancient Greek
and Latin texts and now we're going to
look at those texts to see where it came
from I hope that you all have a handout
nearby or that you have charitable
neighbors the earliest text that
survives which talks about weeping
Herick lightest and laughing Democritus
is printed in 1a it is from sodium of
Alexandria who flourished in the
beginning of the second century BC and
was probably a peripatetic although we
know little about him this passage from
his book on anger is quoted in stony
is's anthology and what he says is among
the sages Heraclitus was overcome by
tears instead of by anger and Democritus
by laughter after that he goes on to
become a widespread commonplace in Greek
and Latin literature I've given you two
important passages from Seneca and then
below the second one a list of some
other passages of the other passage is
probably the most important one but I
didn't give it because it's so long is
in Luke II
the sale of philosophers which was a
very important text in the 15th century
because Luciano was one of the ways that
people learned to write and speak
ancient Greek so if you look at the
Seneca passages whenever her oklet's
went from his house and saw all around
him so many men who were living a
wretched life no rather were dying a
wretched death he would weep and all the
joyous and happy people he met stirred
his pity he was gentle hearted but too
weak and was himself one of those who
had need of pity democracy on the other
hand it is said never appeared in public
without laughing
so little did the serious pursuits of
man seem serious to him where in all
this is there room for anger everything
gives cause for other for either
laughter or tears and much the same said
and the other set in Seneca passage
these ancient Greek and Latin texts
raised at once three easy questions
which I think we can get out of the way
in order to look at more difficult or
more interesting ones the first question
is did so T on text 1a invent this
opposition or is he merely our earliest
witness for it it's impossible to know
because we've lost so much but my own
suspicions is SOT invented it himself
well we know about so T on who was that
he was a historian of philosophy and
that he wrote 23 books of successions
which was which were much used by
diogenes laërtius in which he grouped
the philosophers in terms of the
affinities and contrasts between their
doctrines and talked about how each one
had studied with his predecessor his
predecessor his predecessor in order to
create lines of succession this is
somebody who likes to put philosophers
together and who might well have come up
with the idea of putting together
Heraclitus and Democritus there are also
as we will see Thea frosty in' and
earlier pathetic aspects to this whole
story and if sodium was and seems
possible a peritectic that might make it
slightly likely we can't know but I
wouldn't be surprised if we someday find
out that he did invent it
second easy question did the later
ancient authors who talked about weeping
Herick lightest and laughing Democritus
derive this idea directly from sodium
they said did they read so T on and find
out about that way I don't think that
that's very likely this became a kind of
biographical commonplace and it floated
around in the vast magma of Hellenistic
popular culture where later authors
found it
sodium himself in his book on
successions was abridged by Pericles
limbus in the middle of the 1st century
BC and you can see how sodium is
becoming disseminated said where and
people are reading him indirectly sodium
was not a great scholar but he was a
scholar and the people who read him were
people like diogenes laërtius and Tobias
and not let's say Luke Ian's third easy
question did the Renaissance artists who
painted or etched such images ultimately
derive this idea from sodium directly
directly I did derive this idea from
sodium I'm sure that this was not the
case sodium was only transmitted in
stowe pious and stowe bias was an author
for scholars he was not available in
translation into Latin or the vernacular
at this stage whereas Seneca was one of
the most popular authors of the
Renaissance and in particular the day
era on anger was widely read I'm pretty
sure that Seneca was the most important
source for the Renaissance images
perhaps all solution so let's get that
out of the way that all leaves us with a
fourth question which is a much more
interesting and difficult one whoever
invented this I
the weeping Heraclitus laughing
Democritus whether it was sodium or
somebody else how did he come up with
the idea where did he get it from what
did it mean what what is the opposition
where does the opposition come from and
what is its meaning I'm going to begin
by separating Heraclitus and Democritus
and look at how they are looked at in
antiquity and then I'll come back later
and put them back together again so let
us begin with the biographical
traditions regarding Democritus and
Herick lightest all of these reports are
later than sodium but they indicate the
general view of the lives and characters
of these two early Greek philosophers in
such a way that we can ask whether that
was how people came up with the
opposition let's start with Democritus
text 2a is from I a Lian 3rd century AD
and I'll quote it for you the abbe de
rites called Democritus philosophy the
Rockets came from Abdera Democritus
laughed at everyone and said they were
crazy and that is why his fellow
citizens called him laugher the same
people say that when Democritus met him
for the first time he thought that
Democritus was crazy but as they spent
more time together he came to admire the
man enormous Lee so we have here a text
about Democritus saying that he laughs
and makes fun of people fun of people
and says that they are crazy that
Hippocrates at first his suspicious
becomes to admire him what I a lien is
drawing from is an epistolary novel that
we have let's say an exchange of
inauthentic letters that I've given you
some texts from under to be in this
series of letters the abbe de Rights
write to Hippocrates Hippocrates is the
greatest doctor of antiquity and they're
worried about their fellow students and
Democritus who they think is crazy
because he's laughing all the time
so Hippocrates comes to obdurate to see
and he decides that Democritus is
completely sane and is a first-rate
philosopher and that the people who are
crazy are the abbe de rights and that
Democritus is perfectly justified and
laughing at them what is interesting for
me in this in these passages here is
that if you ask why is Democritus
laughing there are two kinds of answers
that the text 1b 2b gives on the one
hand democracy is happy he is a diamond
and he's tranquil he has Hazen here on
the other hand
Democritus is laughing out of scorn for
human folly so there's one kind of
laughter in democracy which is self
content and there's another kind which
is aggressive and satirical and the text
hasn't really decided which it is it
floats between both of them this is
enough I think to show that the idea of
laughing Democritus is very well
established in the ancient biographical
tradition though the oscillation between
tranquil happiness on the one hand and
scornful mockery on the other is
interesting and I was going to come back
to that well what about her clay does
with her ik latest the reports about his
character and biography and antiquity
give a very very different picture from
what we might expect I've given you a
selection in 3a
according to die end to end under three
under three a diogenes laërtius says
that her ik lattice was arrogant
scornful and angry when he when the
Ephesians gathered around him while he
played dice with the children he asked
why are you surprised you wretched you
riches is it not better to do this than
to engage in politics with you in text
be diogenes laërtius says that he was
haughty and contemptuous
in text see Timon the satiric poet says
that he was a lowly Doris
somebody who reviled the mob Tex D is
from the Greek anthology it's an epigram
that calls him the dog that barked at
the common people in text e we have an
angry dialogue between the dead
Heraclitus and a passerby usually when
there are arts and funerary epigrams the
dead person wants to be nice to the
passerby and and asks him to say nice
things about him to get this Heraclitus
there's nothing but insult the person
who goes past him and ends up wishing
him to run away as soon as possible I
could give you more passages but they
would all point in the same direction
namely that weeping Herick ladis is
completely absent from the ancient
biographical tradition
Heraclitus is always reported to be
angry and score of all scornful never
pitying and weeping now go back to the
first text of so T on that I gave you
under one an a what so T on Rights is
that among the sages
Herick latest was overcome by tears
instead of by anger and democritus by
laughter it looks as though so T on
recognizes that anger is a typical part
of what people expect to be associated
with Heraclitus and he's correcting that
tradition he doesn't he said the reason
he says by tears instead of by anger may
well suggest that everybody before him
thought it was anger and he's saying no
he's deflecting it and pushing it
towards towards pity so we have we would
have if that's correct
the moment in which the tradition goes
in a different direction now in all of
the accounts of hurich lightest is
character and biography there's one pass
exception which I have been saving for
this part of the lecture which is text
for a another passage from dodges
laërtius in which Theophrastus says that
something and I'll come back to that in
a moment
was because of her acquaintances
melancholy so Theophrastus said that her
ik latest was melancholy and explained
something we'll come back to that in a
moment on the basis of this melancholy
could this be the source of the notion
of weeping her GLaDOS was hairy clay is
weeping because he was depressive if so
if it was the source of that this is
almost certainly not what Theophrastus
himself meant when he invoked melancholy
for us melancholy is a emotional state
of sadness and depression but for most
of ancient medicine melancholy was an
imbalance in the humors which you had
too much black bile and the largest and
most interesting discussion of it from
antiquity is the passage I've given you
parts of in for B this is from the work
called the problema to the problems
which is ascribed to Aristotle and which
is transmitted because it was ascribed
to Aristotle but which is at least this
part almost certainly not by Aristotle
but by an early perfect etic perhaps
thea francis if not somebody from that
neighborhood this is chapter book 30
chapter 1 it is the most extended
earlier pathetic discussion of
melancholy that we have as I said we
think of melancholy as depression or
sadness or we penis but for problema to
30.1 that is not the point
instead what melancholy is
is annex is the extremes of
inconsistency on Oh Malia it is
expressed by an oscillation between an
excess of excitement and an excess of
lethargy we might think of it as manic
depression or as a bipolar illness I'll
quote for you a couple of passages now
the melon towards the bottom of the
right column on page three
now the melancholic mixture is itself
inconsistent just as it produces
inconsistency in those with the
melancholic diseases for like water and
sometimes cold and sometimes hot and
then at the bottom therefore when the
mixture from the black bile becomes of
colder as we said as was said it
produces all kinds of spiritless nests
what is hot or cheerfulness so to sum up
because the power of the black bile is
uneven inconsistent melancholic people
are uneven for the black bile becomes
both very cold and very hot
I think that this notion of melancholy
as being inconsistency is almost
certainly with your fascist meant
because look now a text for C and that's
the whole sentence that I gave you in
for a Theophrastus says that it was
because of his melancholy that
Heraclitus left some things unfinished
and rewrote others in different ways
that's to say he invokes Pericles his
melancholy not in order to explain why
Heraclitus wept or felt pity but instead
to explain why her éclairs writings are
inconsistent
Herick latest didn't finish certain
things and then he wrote some things and
then changed him you can't get a single
clear doctrine out of her Aquinas as
people have discovered over millennia of
attempting to do so this acquaintance
Theophrastus was because her class
himself was inconsistent and ever and
that this was because he had too much
black bile Heraclitus his writings are
uneven because Heraclitus was
melancholic ie uneven it's worth noting
that there are various passages in the
Hippocratic writings in which melancholy
disease is connected with speech
problems or defects like stuttering and
aphasia for example I've given you one
in text for Dean
that is to say melancholy is being
invoked in order to explain problems of
expression discursive issues just as
Theophrastus is doing here so I think
that Theophrastus did not mean that her
class was weeping but might fear fascist
his characterization of her GLaDOS as
having been melancholy have been
misinterpreted by later authors as
meaning that her class was weeping if
you look at in text e F and G you'll see
that medical authors sometimes identify
melancholy with sadness
already one hippocratic text does so
fear or depression do slimier that is
prolonged means melancholia and then in
later antiquity it becomes fairly
widespread so I've given you calluses
and our Tyus to writers of the imperial
period the fact that Hippocrates and
later authors sometimes identify
melancholy with sadness or sorrow might
conceivably have meant that Theophrastus
his use of melancholy in order to
explain something else about her oklet's
was misunderstood and thereby
contributed to the image of a weeping
Heraclitus so far we've been looking at
ancient reports about the character and
biographies of democracies on the one
hand and her clothes on the other well
it's worth asking what relation these
images of their characters might have to
the actual philosophical doctrines of
these thinkers very often in antiquity
by graphical reports are derived
directly or indirectly from the writings
of the author's involved and then
they're invented in order to explain the
writings
could these biographical reports have
arisen out of an interpretation of these
philosophers philosophical texts let's
begin with Democritus again because the
case of Democritus is much easier in the
case of Heraclitus i've given you in 5a
the crucial text for our equipment for
Democritus is moral theory once a gum
once again comes from studious and I'll
read it to you because it's interesting
in a number of ways for contentment a
Fumiya comes about for human beings from
the moderation of enjoyment and
proportion in life I'll skip a little
therefore you must direct your thoughts
to what is possible and be satisfied
with what is present maintaining only a
small memory the things that quote
envy and admiration and not sitting and
watching them in thought and you must
observe the lives of those who are
distressed thinking of their great
sufferings so that what is present to
you and what belongs to you
appears to be great an envy of all and
so that it no longer happens to you that
because you desire more you suffer in
your soul for when one admires those who
have riches and are considered happy by
other people and sits and constantly
watches them at every hour in one's
memory one is obliged always to invent
something new and to desire eagerly
because of the passion to do some
irreparable deed one of those things
that the laws prohibit that is why one
must not seek certain things and must be
contented with regard to other ones
comparing one's own life to that of
those who are less successful and must
consider myself happy reflecting upon
what they suffer
to what degree one succeeds and passes
one life better than they do for if you
hold fast to this thought you will pass
your life with greater contentment and
you will drive away quite a few sources
of destruction in life envy rivalry and
hostility the basic concept in
democracies moral theory is contentment
a Fumiya that your themost is in a happy
state this comes from self-control and
from moderation you are supposed to look
at other people and compare their
outcomes with your own but you're
supposed to do so without envying them
their successes and without scorning
their failures happiness comes from the
recognition of the evils of which we
ourselves are free we're not happy
because other people are afflicted by
them we're happy because we ourselves
are exempt from them I've given you in
five B C D and E some other passages in
which give you democracies or moral
theory and they confirm the image that
this one longer passage from still
this gives us five be the best thing for
a man is to pass his life as far as
possible in contentment and as little as
possible in distress this will be the
case if one does not set one's pleasures
upon mortal things much the same in DNA
in fact there's a passage 5f
which is ascribed to Democritus by
studious but for which there is
consensus that's not democracy himself
but pseudo Democritus one of those
prolific authors of the Imperial period
which says those who derive pleasure
from the adversities of their neighbors
not only do not understand that what
belongs to fortune is shared by all
people in common but also they are
deprived of their own joy so here you
have people who take pleasure in other
people's failures being criticized not
by Democritus but by somebody that could
be identified with Democritus what this
should all remind you of or this reminds
me of that is the beginning of book 2 of
Lucretia's his day rate on that Torah
which I've given you in 5g Lucretia's
says what a wonderful thing it is to
stand on the shore and to look out at a
shipwreck and then he says that it's not
that you're happy because those people
are suffering do you feel pleasure at
the sorrows from which you yourself are
exempt this
contentment that one feels is not joy or
pleasure it shouldn't be laughter it
should be more like a sigh of relief but
there's a very interesting passage 5h
again endangered diogenes laërtius in
which algae says the goal is contentment
which is not the same thing as pleasure
as some people have taken it on the
basis of a misinterpretation that is to
say this contentment was misunderstood
by some people as being pleasure as
something that could make you laugh so
what we can say I think is that the
biography of Democritus as a laugher is
based upon a misinterpretation of his
philosophy but an easily understandable
misinterpretation that there is a shift
between contentment and laughter which
we also saw in that facility novel
between Hippocrates and the abbe de
rites in text to be so Democritus is
pretty easy
what about Heraclitus well I've put
together a small selection of passages
from her acquaintances own fragments
under number six there is nothing in any
of her classes philosophical fragments
that suggests weeping or pity or sorrow
and human folly instead the fragments
always are polemical angry scornful
texts 6a other men are unaware of all
they do when there are other men than me
are unaware of all they do when they are
awake just as they forget all they do
when they are asleep text B although the
account is in common most people live as
though they had their own thought tech C
Prather says rightly then the noble
Heraclitus curses the mass of men as
being mindless in
no text D all the adult Ephesians or to
hang themselves and to leave the city to
beardless boys text e much learning does
not teach intelligence for otherwise it
would have taught it to his PC it and
Pythagoras and again tis an often ease
and heck ideas text F he said that Homer
deserved to be driven out of the
competitions and thrashed and our
Killick is likewise text G regarding the
knowledge of things that are evident
humans are fooled in the same way as
Homer texts H Pythagoras much learning
evil artifice so we conclude easily that
there is no support in the fragments of
Heraclitus for the idea of a weeping
philosopher instead the fragments are
just like the character reports of the
biographic tradition mainly anger and
scorn there's one possible exception
here to which I'm doubtful about but
which I want to bring to your attention
and that's text 7a from the Hippocratic
regimen if but if the fire should be
mastered to a greater extent by the
water in the soul we have in cases of
what are called by some senseless people
and by others grossly stupid
now the imbecility of such people
inclines to slowness they weep for no
reason and then it goes on this text
says that if there's too much water in
the soul it dominates over the fire and
makes people weep too much this
Hippocratic treatise is unusual in that
is completely full of her Akutan
languages language phrases even syntax
clearly what the text shows is not just
occasional reminiscences of her ik
lightest but a deliberate self
positioning
within a specifically hurric latin
philosophical and scientific tradition
it's trying to be like her Aquinas might
this Hippocratic passage have arisen as
an interpretation of a Huracan doctrine
that we don't have because presumably
author had more of her claims than we do
well I've given you in 7 B C D and F a
series of fragments in her aquinas about
the relation between soul and water
sometimes there is a hostile
relationship between soul and water text
E which is textually very uncertain and
text F sometimes it's a more complicated
relation text B C and D and there's one
text C in which there's a connection
between souls water and pleasure it's
not possible on this basis I think to
establish a clear and univocal doctrine
of Heraclitus on the relation between
Souls and water in any event none of
them says anything about weeping could
these passages or some other passage
that has been lost have been taken by
this Hippocratic author to suggest that
her ik latest thought that a watery soul
tended to weep and could someone have
supposed that her ik lightest was
talking about himself or have applied
this idea to him perhaps maliciously
that's not entirely impossible but it
seems unlikely to me that even if so
this could have made a significant
contribution to the idea of the weeping
philosopher but it's possible so far
what have we come up with it is easy to
understand how Democritus could have
been misinterpreted as a laughing
philosopher this was simply due to a
banal izing psychological
misunderstanding of his doctrine of a
Fumiya of contentment but it is very
difficult indeed to see how anyone could
have ever imagined her latest as weeping
rather than as angry
so far we've been looking at her
aquellas and democracy but clearly
that's enough not enough Heraclitus
separately from the connection with
Democritus is never weepy he's always
angry in connection and democracy
he's always we be so let's try to look
at Heraclitus and democracy together now
maybe we should look beyond the ancient
texts that I given you two ancient
artworks after all the Renaissance
reception is mostly though not only
based in the visual arts might this have
been the case in antiquity as well well
first of all no ancient visual depiction
of weeping Herick lightest or of
laughing Democritus or of the two of
them together has survived there is on
the other hand one literary description
of paintings of weeping Heraclitus and
laughing Democritus that is text eight a
letter of savonius Apollinaris a fifth
century Christian authored from goal
I'll read it to you you do not burn with
these rights to his correspondent you do
not burn with envy at the thought of
those paintings all over the game nausea
of the areopagus and in the Putin ayah
showing specifics with his head bowed
forward aratus with his head bent back
Zenon was knitted brow Epicurus
with unwrinkled skin Diogenes with long
beard Socrates with trailing hair
Aristotle without thrust arms in aqua
tease with gathered leg Heraclitus with
egg eyes closed though weeping
Democritus with lips wide open with
laughter Chris ipis with fingers bent to
denote Counting Euclid with fingers
extended because of the size of the
measurements CLE Anthes with fingers nor
for both reasons this is a text it
survives is it a description of a real
set of
artworks that actually existed and he's
referring to or is it an actress's of
literary exercise in which he imagines
what that could be like literary
accuracies of non existing paintings
were a whole genre in antiquity and we
have a number of collections of them but
the fact that he's written this means
that at least somebody could imagine
such paintings it doesn't prove that the
paintings existed but it proves that
somebody thought that they might have
existed that it wasn't completely
implausible
so that the pictorial juxtaposition of
laughing democracy and weeping Herick
ladies could be imagined
certainly by a writer perhaps by a
painter or by his patron this passage
from sidonis Apollinaris is interesting
in another regard for it repeats the
apparent the pairing of antithetical
couples like Heracles and Democritus in
a context of a series of such pairings
so we begin with specific and Hirata's
head forward head back Zeno and Epicurus
frowning tranquil Diogenes and Socrates
a long beard long hair
Aristotle's and aqua tease the arm stuck
out the leg bent back Heracles and
Democritus krzepice Euclid Klee Anthes
after the series of two it closes with
three fingers bent penis extended
fingers gnawed in some of these cases
it's very easy to see how a certain
degree of knowledge about their
philosophy could have led to this
imagining of them so Diogenes the cynic
has a long beard Socrates who is closely
connected with the cynics has long hair
Zeno frowns because of the concentration
and getting the dialectic exactly right
Epicurus is tranquil because he believes
in author ox eeeh so there's some degree
of familiarity with the ancient
philosophers at least from Ducks ography
at least from general histories
presupposed here might the visual arts
have
made some contribution to developing the
idea of an antithesis between Herick
lettuce and Democritus because what is
remarkable in sodium and in this whole
tradition including Suetonius
Apollinaris is not only the individual
interpretations of these two
philosophers but also their combination
in a complementary and antithetical
couple where might the idea of come of
combining two figures in such an
complementary and antithetical couple
have come from there are a whole series
of double Herms
in antiquity in which you have a herm
not just with one person but with two
put on opposite sides which are set into
some kind of antithetical and
complementary relationship to one
another here we have two historians here
we have two poets here we have two
epicurean philosophers here we have two
philosophers a Greek one in a Roman one
could there have been a double herm of
Herick lattice and Democritus there's
not a shred of evidence for it that
doesn't mean it didn't exist but we have
a lot of firms we know of portraits of
authors that were set up in libraries in
gardens in stoas but no I bust has ever
been identified singly or doubly as
either hurich lightest or as Democritus
or as both besides if you think that
this is where it begins then you still
can't explain
weeping Heraclitus why is Heraclitus the
one who is put with Democritus well as
we saw you can get to this pair if you
start with Democritus but you can't get
to this pair if you start with
Heraclitus so maybe this is not really
about democracy and Heraclitus let's
instead consider not in that is consider
in weeping Heraclitus and laughing
Democritus not Heraclitus and Democritus
but weeping
and laughing and if we do that then the
source of the inspiration for this
opposition becomes obvious namely
tragedy and comedy the genre that
produces weeping and the genre that
produces laughter the complementarity
and opposition between tragedy and
comedy was anchored in the festival of
Dionysus at Athens where you had tragedy
and then satyr plays and then comedies
and above all it was theorized in the
Academy and in the Perry patos I've
given you 9a a text by Plato from the
Republic in which tragedy and comedy
together make up in their opposition in
the genre of the mimetic mode of
presentation and I've given you a text
in 9b from Aristotle where he talks
about the opposed effects upon the
viewers of tragedy and comedy we know to
come back to the Africa Theophrastus
that Theophrastus theorized tragedy and
comedy and talked about their
differences
unfortunately the details are entirely
uncertain because all we have is reports
that go back to Theophrastus from late
ancient grammarians and we don't have
anything that can be regarded as a
quotation of more than a few words so I
think that the ultimate inspiration for
this opposition was not artistic but
literary and philosophical out of the
tread out of the opposition tragic tears
comic laughter was created weeping
Heraclitus laughing Democritus there's
to say the faces of Democritus and her
oklet's were superimposed upon the masks
of comedy and tragedy once they were
created the muscle it was this
opposition was created it could be
divorced from comedy and tragedy
and be reinterpreted in terms of popular
culture as different philosophical
attitudes to human ills essentially sat
a satirical this was easier to do for
Democritus because the whole tradition
associated him with laughter than it was
for Heraclitus how did her ik lightest
his anger get interpreted as as tears
must we think that so tea on or someone
else became thought that Heraclitus was
so angry that he started to cry out of
frustration above all and here is the
point that I find most problematic in
this whole story and would be enormous
ly grateful to for all of your help why
once you decide to have Democritus and
somebody else for comedy and tragedy why
pick Heraclitus for a tragedy and in
particular if you wanted to have a one
of the people that they used to quote
free Socratic s-- why do you pick
Heraclitus instead of picking in pedicle
ease and peda Cleese was a philosopher
who was known to have killed himself by
throwing himself into a volcano if you
look at texts of 10 a B C and D I've
given you some passages from impetus
--is poetry in which he expresses sorrow
and pity and tears for other people and
for himself in 10-8 he goes through aqua
Gus and everybody follows him and
worships him like a God because he can
help them he wants to make their lives
better
Tex B I wept and wailed when I saw an
unaccustomed place taxi
alas wretched race of mortals miserable
race from such kinds of strife and such
from such groans as are you born and
text nd he pities himself for having
mede and thereby heaven condemned
himself to wandering in the book 30
chapter 1 of the pseudo Aristotelian
problema de that I gave you earlier the
first sentence lists famous cases of
melancholy and the first person is
impetus that's text for B now in later
times of the well-known people there are
empennage
Socrates and many others so why didn't
he choose in pedicle e's instead of
Heraclitus is it that Herick ladis was
more present in popular culture than in
pedicle e's was is it that impetus e's
was looked at in a different way I wish
that I knew and maybe one of you does in
any event my suspicion is that there
were never any ancient busts of the pair
of Hercules and Democrat and and
Democritus but as so often happens
neoclassicism sprang in to fill the
holes that classical antiquities ruins
had left vacant or that classical
antiquity had prudently never filled
there are indeed portrait busts of this
pair but they're never found before the
18th century here is Bharat as here's
Bharata here is Luca and here's another
by Luca who is particularly fond of this
and even today the pair of weeping
hurich ladis and laughing Democritus has
not been entirely forgotten but survives
in the vast magma of the internet I
don't know if you can read that if you
want I'll read it to you Heraclitus
I told everyone to listen not to me but
rather to the logos of the universe but
people don't listen to me a new Sun
rises each day but my sadness is still
the same hahahahahaha
ha what is so funny Democritus you think
there is a Sun there is no Sun there are
only atoms in the void ha ha ha ha ha
classic Heraclitus
[Music]